this demo highlights one of our newest
bigquery features
time unit partitioning this feature
allows you to organize time-based data
using flexible units of time
ranging from an hour to a year to see
this feature in action
let's work with the bigquery public data
set on wikipedia page views this data
set contains a timestamp column called
date hour if you are familiar with
creating daytime partition tables
you know that you can use daytime trunk
and specify
a datetime column and a parameter for
the time component in this case
hour for this data set the query editor
warns us that the data set does not
contain a column called date type
recall from our review of the data set
that it actually contains a timestamp
column called date hour
to modify this query for time unit
partitioning you can simply replace
daytime trunk with timestamp trunk and
daytime column
with the date hour column
with the time component set as hour the
query will create
an hourly partition table you can easily
create a daily partition table by
replacing hour with day
last you can create a daily partition
table with clustering by adding cluster
by date hour
using these three versions of the query
i have created the tables listed under a
data set called time unit
taking a look at the details of the
hourly partition table
you can see that it contains just over
12.7 billion records
and that it is partitioned by hour on
the date hour column
the details for the daily partition
table show the same number of rows and
that it is partitioned
by day on the date hour column the daily
partition table with clustering
shows similar information the difference
being that it is also clustered
on the date hour column to compare the
performance of these time unit
partitioning schemes let's run a few
queries to select some hourly data
first let's select some data for a
specific one and a half hour window from
the daily partition table
note that the estimated amount of data
processed for this query is six gigs
while the query may not take long to run
selecting all data for that one and a
half hour window from the daily
partition table
ended up processing the entire six gigs
of data let's run the same selection on
the hourly partition table to see the
difference in performance
on the hourly partition table the same
query is estimated to process noticeably
less data
about 575 megs of data running the query
shows that indeed it only processed
about 575 megs of data
for comparison let's write the same
query on the daily partition table with
clustering
notice that the estimated amount of data
processed for this query
is again six gigs running this query
highlights that the hourly partition
table performs similarly to a daily
partition table with clustering but with
a more straightforward implementation
for example recall that the estimate of
data processed for the daily participle
was six gigs the same as the estimate
for the daily partition table of
clustering
even though the query on the cluster
table ended up processing
less data limiting the selection further
to a 45-minute window shows the true
benefit of hourly partitioning
the query on the daily partition table
still has to process six gigs of data
however the hourly partition table only
has to process 281 megs of data
running the query shows that it indeed
only processed 281 megs
now that you have seen time unit
partitioning in action we hope that you
are excited to try it out on your
time-based data
be sure to check out the bigquery docs
to learn more and keep an eye out for
the release notes to stay informed about
other exciting features headed your way